le sport et le TVB va tenter de
remporter une onzième Coupe de France ce
sera le 2 avril à Paris face à Nice pour
décrocher leur ticket en finale les
leaders de la Ligue A ce sont
débarrassés de Narbonne victoire 3 7 à 0
hier soir à Grenon le résumé de la
rencontre avec Clémence d'OSC
la victoire en trois sets pour le Tour
volley-ball hier soir les tours enjos se
sont imposés lors de cette demi-finale
de la Coupe de France face à Narbonne
qui s'est tout de même bien défendu je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de mérites dans
notre de notre équipe contre une
vaillante équipe de Narbonne qui qui
joue très bien à ces moments et qui nous
a mis la pression tous les temps avec un
service de folie et des attaquants un
deux et quatre qui sont très forts un
bon début de premier set mené 5 un par
tour les eaux doivent se ressaisissent
pour diminuer cet écart mais le TVB
finit de remporter le 7 25 à 19
[Applaudissements]
pour le tour de l'école maximum de bruit
les narbonnés montant puissance vers la
fin du deuxième set et parviennent à
égaliser à 22 23 et 24 avant de céder 26
à 24 face à Dramé
dernier set qui débute sous les chapeaux
de roue pour Narbonne en avance avec 1 à
6 pas question de relâcher la pression
les hommes de Marcelo francoviak ont
tenu bon et arracher la victoire 25 à 22
le gros point positif c'est que dans le
3e siècle même quand on est mené on fait
aider des exploits individuels et
collectif donc ça c'est une vraie force
c'est bien pour la suite on a un double
enjeu faut qu'on fasse passer le goût
amer dans l'an dernier et que on gagne
le titre cette année donc il y a pas de
il y a pas de peur il y a que de l'envie
et on a un double projet quoi là
direction la finale de la Coupe de
France pour la quatrième année
consécutive rendez-vous le 2 avril
prochain face à Nice pour faire de la
défaite de l'année passée contre
Chaumont un lointain souvenir
[Applaudissements]